welcome back everybody las vegas
restaurant week is underway and it's the
perfect way
to get out and give back see how
enjoying a steakhouse dinner will help
you feed hungry families
[Music]
we are cooking up back here for
restaurant week chef tell us where we
are
we're at steakhouse my name is rory gau
executive chef we're going to talk about
restaurant week yeah what's on the menu
you get your choice of soup and salad
and the entree is a 10 ounce fillet
let's see here
you also get a choice of side and then a
choice of either a creme brulee or a
cheesecake so all of our steak comes
from nebraska
it's aged 21 days
look at that wow what makes a perfect
steak here
what makes the perfect steak salt and
pepper oh see it's simple
it's simple and then of course the sides
back there they're stuffing up what are
the sides let's go through the list so
there's truffle fries
truffle mac and cheese which is really
good
wow i'm sorry what'd you say
now brian you're no stranger to cooking
in the kitchen we've got 5 000 square
foot kitchen at three square
so no you're right wow okay so tell us
what you're making
this is macaroni and cheese otherwise
known as god's gift to humanity
we love this i mean this is amazing amen
yeah you wanna throw some chives on
there oh absolutely yeah you can't have
too many chocolates we are so excited
about restaurant wig now through the
18th of june
the premier culinary event for las vegas
125 restaurants
and guess what when you dine out you get
to create three meals for people in need
it doesn't get any better than that
and we're also giving back to local
restaurants at the same time as well
absolutely we are asking them to retain
some of those uh profits so that they
can get back on their feet we love our
culinary community we feel for what
they've been through this past year
and this is the great time if you
haven't re-engaged and come out it's
safe
people are so eager to get back in the
flow of things and the chef at the
culinary scene and here the edge
steakhouse has never been better than
that now for people who might not want
to enjoy the restaurant scene just
yet you guys have options for them as
well absolutely they'll go to
restaurantweeklv.org
they can see which restaurants are
offering take out
and dine out almost all of them are
offering that so imagine getting a
specially priced meal
at a super high-end restaurant that you
normally wouldn't go to you think well i
can't really afford it
restaurant week now through the 18th you
can afford it
and you can do it safely on your terms
you're in control
and you're helping feed kids and seniors
in our community that really need us to
to support this event we don't need any
more incentives than that but you know
what i do need
what to try this mac and cheese that
you've been making i see that hunger in
your eyes
hey chef where's the finished product i
got my fork ready
oh wow all right oh my god look at that
smells so good okay
if i burn my mouth i want a free meal
how is it delicious oh my gosh
it smells so good yeah yeah look at all
this look at this
[Music]
you can enjoy las vegas restaurant week
while giving back to the three square
food bank restaurants across the valley
are participating through june 18th
for more information just head to
restaurantweeklv.org kendall